la proposition première du Rip proposait
de
modifier la loi pour dire que 62 ans
était le plafond or actuellement
les 62 ans c'est un plancher et donc on
pouvait considérer que passer de
plancher à plafond était une est une
réforme le Conseil constitutionnel en a
décidé autrement il y a donc eu une
divergence d'interprétation sur la
compréhension du mot réforme
ce qui me paraît aujourd'hui en tous les
cas très
probable c'est qu'on regarde la
jurisprudence désormais stable du
Conseil constitutionnel le la seconde
demande de référendum d'initiative
partagée sera vraisemblablement comme la
première repoussée par le Conseil
constitutionnel qu'est-ce qui change
véritablement entre entre les deux
textes celui qui avait été refusé le 14
avril dernier et celui et bien examiné
par le Conseil constitutionnel ces
jours-ci
sont les arguments des opposants à la
réforme alors ceux qui changent c'est
que dans le nouveau projet il y a un
article 2 qui prévoit une contribution
fiscale exceptionnelle pour combler le
déficit des régimes de retraite or
l'article 11 de la Constitution ne
permet pas de faire un référendum sur
des dispositions de nature fiscale par
conséquent le Conseil constitutionnel
aura simplement à dire ce qu'il a déjà
dit dans une décision du 25 octobre 1902
2022 on ne peut pas faire un référendum
en France sur une question
fiscale alors plus plus largement plus
généralement quels sont les conditions
pour mettre un oeuvre un RIP on va voir
ensemble que elles sont finalement assez
compliquées voire quasiment impossible
finalement à réunir ces conditions
quasiment impossible et même son nom
référendum d'initiative partagée c'est
plutôt référendum d'initiative
parlementaire dans la mesure où il faut
pour lancer la procédure il faut qu'il y
ait un cinquième des parlementaires qui
propose le référendum c'est à dire à peu
près 185 190 parlementaires pour lancer
la procédure ensuite il faut 4 millions
900 000 électeurs qui signent cette
proposition un dixième du corps
électoral mais même s'il y a ces 4
millions 900 000 le projet doit être
examiné par le Parlement et par
conséquent le Parlement peut bloquer un
référendum en examinant la proposition
autrement dit le Parlement à
l'initiative et le Parlement peut
bloquer le référendum en examinant la
proposition qui aura ou aurait recueilli
4 millions 900 000 signatures donc ça
veut dire que c'est quoi qu'il en soit
quel que soit la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est finalement le
Parlement qui a le dernier mot sur
l'organisation ou non de ce fameux
référendum vous avez totalement raison
c'est le Parlement qui a raison parce
que c'est lui qui lance la procédure et
c'est lui qui peut la bloquer en
décidant de l'examiner alors comment
est-ce que le Conseil constitutionnel
avait motivé sa première décision pour
cette décision qui avait rejeté cette
cette première demande du Rip alors le
Conseil avait motivé sur le mot réforme
le aujourd'hui la loi dit la retraite
est à 62 ans et le Conseil
constitutionnel a considéré que la
proposition de référendum ne modifiez
pas le droit existant puisque déjà
de la retraite est à 62 ans donc il n'y
avait pas de modification de l'état du
droit et c'est en ce sens que c'est la
raison pour laquelle le Conseil a dit ce
n'est pas une réforme puisque ça
maintient l'état du droit existant alors
en revanche ce qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est que dans un an c'est à
dire en avril ou mai 2024 les
oppositions pourraient refaire une
proposition de référendum d'initiative
partagée à 62 ans parce que là il
s'agirait d'abroger la loi
qui fixe à 64 ans l'âge de la retraite
on ne peut pas faire un référendum
d'initiative partagée pour abroger une
loi qui a été votée il y a moins d'un an
moins d'un an mais en mai 2024 on sera
donc un an après la promulgation de la
loi qui fixe à 64 ans et donc on pourra
demander au mois de mai 2024 on les
oppositions pourront demander
d'organiser un référendum d'initiative
populaire quelle sera la situation du
pays en 2024 évidemment je n'en sais
rien alors j'entends ce que vous ce que
vous dites sur cette éventuelle
troisième demande sur la deuxième
demande celle qui nous occupe ces
jours-ci vous avez entendu le patron des
sénateurs du Parti socialiste Patrick
Kanner qui dit que le texte cette
fois-ci est plus sécurisé en termes
juridique et qu'il a donc plus de
chances d'aboutir est-ce que vous diriez
qu'il a raison avec votre regard de
juriste ou bien ce qu'il s'avance un peu
je dirais qu'il s'avance un peu je pense
que il a tort au regard de jurisprudence
du Conseil constitutionnel je pense que
les sénateurs de l'opposition auraient
dû lire la décision du 25 octobre 2022
du conseil pour voir que rajouter cet
article 2 avec une disposition fiscale
condamnée condamné cette seconde
proposition à la limite la première avec
plus de chance de de passer que la
seconde vous parlez de la de la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
en ce qui concerne le rip que nous dit
justement cette durée c'est
jurisprudence finalement ce référendum
il n'a jamais été mise en oeuvre n'a
jamais été mise en oeuvre je crois qu'il
y a eu quatre ou cinq propositions de
référendum d'initiatives partagées et il
y en a qu'un seul qui a été accepté par
le Conseil constitutionnel vous en
souvenez c'était sur la question de la
privatisation des aéroports de de Paris
où là il s'agissait effectivement d'une
d'une réforme et
l'initiative n'avait pas pu aller
jusqu'au bout parce que le la avait reçu
que 1 million 200000 je crois signatures
des lecteurs alors qu'il faut 4 millions
800.000 signatures donc le référendum
n'avait pas pu aller jusqu'au bout parce
que le seuil d'un dixième des électeurs
est vraiment très élevé que Dieu dans le
chat que je salue nous rejoindre et il
nous dit pourtant face au cas où l'appel
au vote du peuple français et dans la
Constitution qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez on a peur en France d'organiser
des référendums dont on appelait ou vote
direct du peuple je crois qu'il y a une
effectivement en France une méfiance une
distance à l'égard du référendum parce
qu'il y a dans la culture
constitutionnelle française cette idée
que effectivement c'est par le
référendum que la République a été
instaurée en
1792 mais c'est aussi par le référendum
qu'elle a été supprimée par Napoléon en
1804 et ensuite il n'y a eu des
référendums que
plébiscitaires c'est-à-dire on ne
répondait pas à au texte on répondait à
la personne qui pose la question et donc
une certaine méfiance on n'est pas on
n'est pas la Suisse il y a une certaine
méfiance à l'égard de la pratique du
référendum dans quelle mesure est-ce que
les neuf membres du Conseil
constitutionnels peuvent être influencés
par le contexte social le contexte
politique du pays avec par exemple lundi
1er mai dernier de nouveau plus de 780
mille personnes qui ont défilé dans les
rues de France est-ce que cela a une
influence est-ce que les juges du
Conseil constitutionnel regardent ce
type d'événements ils sont consciemment
ou inconsciemment et bien orienté par
par ce type de d'événements alors
consciemment ou inconsciemment je peux
pas rentrer évidemment dans la tête de
chacun des membres du Conseil évidemment
qu'ils sont comme vous et moi ils
regardent ils lisent le Figaro il
regarde votre émission ils écoutent ce
qui se passe mais
le précisément le travail du juge et de
s'extraire au maximum de ces influences
médiatiques politiques pour
essayer de rendre une décision endroit
qui soit la plus distancier par rapport
à l'ambiance à l'ambiance politique je
vous rappelle par exemple que
lors de l'affaire du mariage pour tous
il y a eu des manifestations très
importantes dans le pays contre le
mariage pour tous ça n'a pas empêché de
conseil constitutionnel de déclarer
conforme à la Constitution la loi
Taubira qui reconnaissait le mariage
pour tous donc bien sûr ils écoutent
mais tout leur travail consiste à
prendre une distance à l'égard de de
cette atmosphère politique pour ne juger
qu'en droit pourquoi a-t-il été pensé à
l'origine ce référendum d'initiative
populaire en tous les cas à vous écouter
à vous entendre j'ai le sentiment que
finalement il a été écrit conçu pour ne
jamais être appliqué mais vous avez
totalement raison d'ailleurs ceux qui
l'ont imaginé notamment de leur
commission maladive un comité Balladur
reconnaissent aujourd'hui que ils l'ont
c'est une concession en quelque sorte à
l'air du temps il fallait donner un
message oui le référendum ça fait bien
dans le décor donc on fait le référendum
mais on l'organise de telle manière il
ne peut jamais être mise en œuvre les
ceux qui l'ont pensé reconnaissent
aujourd'hui qu'ils l'ont pensé pour
qu'ils ne soient jamais mis en œuvre ça
veut dire qu'on a joué on a joué avec
les textes en fait on a c'était un effet
d'annonce on a dit on crée ce référendum
pour donner l'illusion que le peuple
peut se saisir d'une question mais en
réalité ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
faisable n'oubliez pas c'était l'époque
c'était Nicolas Sarkozy qui était
Président de la République donc hyper
président déjà disait-on allons parler
pas Jupiter mais d'hyperrésidence donc
pour montrer que non c'était pas
simplement une hyper président mais
qu'il y avait la possibilité de donner
au peuple la voie de s'exprimer on a dit
ils ont dit on va faire un référendum
mais ils l'ont encadré de telle manière
que ce référendum on le voit bien depuis
2008 n'a jamais pu aller jusqu'au
jusqu'à son terme or référendum
d'initiative partagée quels sont les
autres armes constitutionnelles qu'il
reste aux opposants à cette réforme des
retraites
qui a été promulgué le en avril le 15
avril 2023 déjà en 2018 les gilets
jaunes avaient fait du Rick le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne l'une
de leurs principales revendications
quelle différence y a-t-il entre ces
deux procédures alors le RIC comme son
nom l'indique c'est les citoyens qui
prennent l'initiative de demander un
référendum par exemple c'est ce qui se
passe en Italie ou c'est ce qui se passe
en Suisse lorsque 500 000 c'est en
Italie lorsque 500 000 électeurs
demandent l'organisation d'un référendum
sur tel thème et bien le référendum doit
avoir lieu le RIB c'est différent encore
une fois c'est pas les citoyens qui ont
l'initiative ce sont les parlementaires
qui ont l'initiative il faut d'abord
qu'il y ait un cinquième des
parlementaires qui vote une proposition
de référendum avec le risque ce sont les
citoyens qui prennent qui prennent
l'initiative donc ce sont deux
procédures différentes cette fois-ci
est-ce que vous pensez que que le rip
peut être une une solution à cette crise
politique peut-être démocratique que
nous traversons
je suis très réservé à l'égard du
référendum je suis très réservé à
l'égard du référendum pour quelle raison
parce que je pense en tous les réservé à
l'égard d'un référendum sec je pense que
le pays a davantage besoin de délibérer
de discuter d'échanger
du contrat de victoire des arguments et
le référendum notre société est
tellement complexe aujourd'hui qu'on ne
peut pas résoudre une question par oui
ou non la retraite c'est pas 62 ou 64 ça
dépend des métiers ça dépend du moment
où on a commencé à travailler ça dépend
de la manière dont la carrière s'est
déroulée ça dépend de la pénibilité du
travail donc vous pouvez pas dire oui ou
non nous sommes dans une société
complexe qui mérite du compromis qui
mérite de la délibération qui mérite des
échanges d'arguments et le référendum
est un peu un ukase un coup près c'est
oui ou non et je suis très réservé à
l'égard de la pratique du référendum
sans ajouter toutes les questions
comment dire qui actuellement polluent
si vous permettez les campagnes
électorales les fake news les réseaux
sociaux qui fait que le référendum est
davantage l'instrument par lequel on
exprime une émotion en exprime une
spontanéité mais pas une réflexion sur
un problème ou une situation je suis
plutôt alors peut-être trop classique
mais très dans la dans la dans la lignée
disons du siècle des Lumières je crois
plus à la raison des libératives pour
arrêter une décision qu'à la spontanéité
d'une d'une réponse
[Musique]